Okay, this was a tough one. But the answers are the third, the fourth, and the
last answers. Let's take a look at why that is. Just take the first statement by
itself. Affected individuals may carry a dominant allele.
If you're affected, it means you're lactose intolerant,
so we know you must be homozygous recessive
or minus minus. Minus minus, is the recessive condition,
right. This is not having a dominant allele, if
you had a dominant allele, you would be unaffected, so
that can't be true. The second statement says, affected
individuals must carry a dominant allele. Well, no that can't
be true either right, I mean, because if they
can't even have one just as a conditional may, we
know they can't have to have one because that
would definitely make them unaffected, right. They'd be lactose tolerant.
Now the third statement says affected individuals must carry
a recessive allele. The recessive allele in this case is
the minus and we know that affected individuals are
minus minus and this is the only way we get
an affected individual. That it is true, they must
carry at least one recessive allele because they have to
have two recessive alleles in fact. So that's true. The
fourth saying is, unaffected individuals must carry a dominant allele.
So, look at Kate's brother. Remember before, we
didn't know what one of those alleles were, but
we knew for sure that one must be a
dominant plus allele, because he's unaffected. This is definitely
true. The fifth statement says unaffected individuals must carry
a recessive allele. Let's go back to Kate's brother
again. We don't know exactly which allele he has,
but we know that he could have either another
plus allele or minus allele. But, Kate's brother could
in fact be plus plus. An unaffected individual being
plus plus. Those are two dominant alleles. So unaffected
individual don't have to carry a recessive allele. And
that leads us to our last statement. Unaffected individuals
may carry a recessive allele. Again we'll come back
to Kate's brother and say that he could be
plus plus or plus minus. If he's plus minus,
then he sure does have a recessive allele. We could
also look at Kate and her brother's parents and we
see that they're both unaffected and they do carry a
recessive allele themselves. So this last statement is in fact true.